getting some way under sets really easy
because we're trying to make your
experience great so the more information
you can give us before ordering the
dining experience the easier it is for
us to do our job and easier just to get
us on your size easily obviously price
is something that helps us to eliminate
a lot of options off of whitelisted the
other is how much are you going to be
drinking you're using for a glass of
wine a half bottle a bottle or multiple
selection because you're going to have
one bottle of red wine that's got to get
us through salads pastas mains etc
that's a much trickier question than or
a half of like full bottle of red and we
know what we're doing right from there
and then the last is will have drinker
are you are you adventurous you like to
keep it to classics do you want to
experiment with the newest coolest thing
or you like to keep it tried-and-true
either just admit to feast ever up front
and say I don't know anything I just
want to make sure that we're having a
great time and then it becomes a three
person conversation I see it happen more
and more there's this casual just about
I don't know a lot about wine and what
what do you want to do let's make this
about us rather than about me showing
off but if you insist on showing off
which I don't recommend because it's
thinly-veiled that you try not to use
buzzwords or jargon that you don't
really know what they mean you're not
going to out jar in the subway do
include your guests there's nothing
worse to guests being around persons
dominating so ladies times and not
including the rest of the table it makes
you kind of look like a boor do you
express any sort of desync receipts for
example red wine that's a little bit
older I like to finish my glass of red
before someone tops it up and I'm really
explicit and say I'm going to finish my
glass before I get a top up I just like
that better or I like my white wine
really cold or actually I like my white
wine not so cold the explicit give
direction be cool about it be nice
smiles do say thank you thank you goes a
long way the dough on wine corkage is
something that is a little bit difficult
to navigate there is a protocol and you
I think people bring in wise and that's
cool don't presume anything give a call
to his records bossy oh yes it's $35
can I bring as many bottles as I want no
actually we have a limit of two Percival
great I would say one of the things that
driving crazy is unrealistic expectation
of I want to drink what is a thousand
dollar wide experience for 20 bucks so
if you say I love to drink shuts up the
truth and I want to drink them Rollo
just like that you're being a jackass
don't do that